ja wie poker das erste mal dass ich ein
portal gesehen habe wo ich nicht das
gefühl hatte ok wenn ich irgendwo drauf
clique werde ich sofort total arm
obwohl es im bereich poker ist ja ist es
nicht so weit es geht nicht um geld
sondern wir uns was einfallen lassen
erst mal für die für die fans und zwar
original getragene trikots zum beispiel
sachen von superstars aus deutschland
aber auch aus anderen ländern viel im
bereich fußball im moment aber wir
erweitern uns da auch mit anderen stars
zum pokern kann deshalb auch die
turniere monat jeden montag und es
kostet nix alle können kostenlos bezogen
wo ich kann der sinn do ahnungslos ja
wir haben wir haben trotzdem dunkles der
moderator von den herren also wir haben
uns entschieden also bzw marcel hat mich
mal angerufen und wir kennen uns kann
man im projekt angerufen hat gesagt ja
wer ganz kuba vielleicht mal so eine tv
geschichte mit reinbringen ich habe ja
schon so einiges im internet mal gemacht
und
da wollten wir jetzt wie ein poker tv
draus machen da haben wir jetzt schon
mal eine folge draußen die kann man sich
auf youtube angucken auch wenn man so
wie ihr poker tv interviews mit oliver
pocher als matze knop per mertesacker
schon so ein paar einige promis und
machen da so lustige sendungen das ist
so das hauptdeck um die leute ein
bisschen unterhalten die auf der seite
sind auch ein bisschen so ein komplettes
paket mit unterhaltung und
genau das ist der punkt charity also es
gibt essen sensationelle preise aber es
geht auch nicht darum geld zu verdienen
also es geht schon darum geld zu kriegen
aber für was ja es ist gesplittet also
wir hier finanzieren oder wollen das
ganze projekt finanzieren mit mit
unseren sponsoren in zukunft und der
cherry charity gedanke ist der dass man
als user möchte ein button kaufen kann
und demnach ein teil dazu beitragen
diesen button dann wirklich eins zu eins
zum charity aber der hauptaugenmerk
charity wie bei uns das jetzt in zukunft
bauen wollen ist natürlich mit live
events mit coolen stars die den spielen
gegen gegen fans die das sich bei uns
qualifiziert haben über die seite et
cetera und über diesen event dann halt
viele projekte zu unterstützen ist
aktuell im hamburger weg dabei anstatt
im moment die uns unterstützen und wir
wachsen stetig und per mertesacker
stiftung haben wir letztes zugute lassen
und aber wir wollen uns natürlich auch
auf vergrößern und wachsen das machen
mit unseren sponsoren und wollen etwas
aufbauen und für die fans aber wie
gesagt kostenlos und die können echt die
originalen getragenen trikots gewinnen
und die können auch mit promis
direktkontakte kommen über marcel das
sind ja ein paar wirklich so ein
bisschen das ganze mit betreut haben
also zb matze knop wie gesagt ja auch
dabei ist benjamin colin von thomas
müller hatte hat seine preise gestellt
mesut özil hat ja sein wm trikot poldi
hat da weiß man eine geschichte derweil
hat sich auch bereit erklärt jetzt
nächste mal also mertesacker turnier mit
zustellung sein trikot zu geben und aber
auch irgendwo zu verteidigen und das
einfach geil und wir garantieren halt
mit einem mit einem promi stern am
fernseher das wenn das dann ist es auch
der die originale promi und keinen kein
fake oder so und das ist halt ganz
witzig kann man online schon gegen ihn
pokern und der leicht wenn es dann
sozusagen natürliche gründe und wie auch
sie sagt ja auf die idee gekommen ein
paket mit pokern zu machen für mich ganz
einfach pokern ist das beliebteste
kartenspiel wer ist morgen gewesen
hätten auch morgen im körper poker ist
das beliebteste das was in der welt halt
auch jeder kennt damit jeder mitmachen
kann uns auch schnell lernen kann das
bei uns wichtig und warum bekommen wir
immer sagt man pokert um irgendetwas und
heidi stars geben etwas wo die fans und
pokern können und das ist eigentlich der
riesenbeck und wir wollten und da ich
selber auch gerne mal eine runde poker
habe ich gesagt ich möchte in 3d poker
haben ich möchte nicht mehr dieses 2d
sondern wir haben ein sehr aufwendiges
spiel sind uns dann natürlich auch immer
weiter verbessern sieht schon cool aus
der 3d feeling irgendwann vielleicht
auch mal mit mit mit live-übertragungen
et cetera also das ist schon sehr
hochwertig und wir bleiben dran da ich
weiß auch die britischen ok dafür kann
sie ist also erst am anfang ja freut
sich darauf und jeder kann mitmachen
jeder kann mitmachen wir sind am anfang
haben bewusst bewusst nicht so viele
marketing aktion gemacht darüber gesagt
haben sie halten das sind klein weil wir
haben schon sehr viele promis die auch
schon selber gespielt haben mitgemacht
haben und das ist jetzt kein wachstum
haben schon viele anmeldungen aber das
noch nicht so richtig in den köpfen das
kommt jetzt vor allem weil am anfang hat
uns gar keiner geglaubt machte jansen da
ist ja wirklich oder kann man da das
trikot gewinnen und mittlerweile die
haben ja schon osterturnier gehabt mit
einem samy khedira trikot was einer
gewohnt von der wm und ja dass das geht
immer so weiter jetzt und die preise
diesen hochwertigen das ist ja cool
marketing wollen wir jetzt ein bisschen
beginnen und deswegen habe er auch für
dich ein bisschen was mitgebracht doch
wir wollen dich ja auch ein bisschen
präsenten damit das auch jeder und haben
zum einmal ein t shirt wir können
trikottausch machen wir können zu können
wir machen
ja das machen wir
auch so ein bisschen bushido mäßig oder
soja okay so leicht zu wenn dann er
passt super so sie aber auch mal zu
zeigen dass wir auch der wirklichen
portfolio haben das kein spaß ist hier
ist zum beispiel nur eins von vielen das
originale mesut özil trikot mit original
grasflecken aus dem spiel gegen
australien
original durchgeschwitzt auch
oder hier machen wir neu als gelbe wm
trikot oder gegen serbien an gehabt hat
jetzt haben wir zwar aber unterschrieben
natürlich alles original dann geht's
weiter wir haben hier das ist poldi der
uns unterstützt hat und wo alles
original getragen von torben p die haben
von manchester city hier noch eins weil
wir auch hier liegt aktiv sind das erste
trikot von jacko original unterschrieben
als er gewechselt ist zu mancity und da
war jetzt mit marketingaufwand werden
wir nach und nach natürlich auch an die
guten preise auch rangehen er gewarnt
jede wochenende hat was abgrasen und wir
versuchen natürlich werden jetzt
letztens pro panzer hat nur preise also
sind auch mal andere mit dabei bushido
studios arbeit zum beispiel mit karmann
hat ein video bei otv also wir sind ganz
gut dabei wirklich eine tolle an diesen
preisen ist das ist mit geld nicht zu
bezahlen und das kann man ja nicht
kaufen nein absolut nicht es gab ja auch
glaube ich mal in der welt am sonntag
seine statistiken artikel sogar über was
das für den emotionalen art hat
heutzutage und das ist uns bewusst aber
das gute ist ja es ist ja dann auch für
die fans dass die möglichkeit haben
natürlich braucht man dann auch ein
bisschen glück und muss man halt so ein
bisschen bei unserer der seite sich ein
bisschen auskennt ein bisschen zeit
verbringen aber es ist möglich weil du
hast vier turniere die du spielen kannst
und das ist ganz cool und eine rangliste
die tagtäglich gespielt werden kann denn
der erste der rangliste gewinnt fest ein
trikot aus diesem monat hat dann im
ausblick ob dieses mal ist es von von
freiburg der sc der jetzt gerade aktuell
über das eis im moment wenn ihr sagt ihr
seid noch am anfang wenig chancen riesig
darauf wirklich was zu gewinnen
vollkommen richtig so ist es ja was
nichts hinzuzufügen jetzt anmelden es
ist kostenlos alles geil oder ja dann
jeden montag wie gesagt ich bin selber
bei dem turnier mit montag war weil wir
meistens montags auch frei mit dem stern
anderen mit dem stern dran und hätte
dann auch mit den leuten hoffe dass ich
nicht immer so früh rausfliegen sind
mittlerweile die sind richtig trainiert
weil er ist auch eine art pokerschule
weil du in der rangliste hat auch
punktesystem das heißt wenn du nicht gut
spielst oder bewusst versucht das spiel
ein bisschen schlecht zu machen gibt es
ja mal im internet denn viele spielen
ist bei uns so du wirst bestraft und
fällt aus den preisen aus weil wir
bestimmte punkte brauchst oder weiter
kommen muss und das ist halt cool das
ist eine art pokerschule super also für
alle auch für die neuen viele anfänger
alle die poker irgendwie mal
interessiert da können alle mit noch
also etwas wofür wir auch vor allen
dingen gerne werbung machen weil das für
guten zweck ist zum beispiel hamburger
weg was ist das zum beispiel hamburger
weg ist etwas was der hsv und
lebensgefährtin eine organisation die in
hamburg viel auf die beine stellt im
positiven sinne die haben sehr viele
wege die die betreuen dienstwege weil
einfach sachen geebnet werden das heißt
wir haben letztens sogar dann aktionen
gemacht wo wir dann spielplätze
aufgeräumt haben fußballplätze sauber
gemacht haben und es gibt so viele
praktisch gut ist ein projekt was ich
selber schon betreuung habe das einfach
mit reingenommen bei mir neben dem
hamburger weg dann ein check zukommen zu
lassen das haben wir dann gemacht und
das kommt riesig an und so wollen wir es
auch weiter machen und nur für uns ist
auch wichtig wir machen was für guten
zweck wir rocken richtig aber die seite
ist das ziel das ich finanziert weil wir
möchten arbeitsplätze schaffen möchten
was rocken das über sponsoren geht und
der button und die live events ist dann
wirklich da haben wir dann richtig rein
ist da was zusammenkommen und da sind
auf dem guten weg wir hatten drei vier
gute aktion schon und front ich drücke
die daumen und bin sehr gespannt vielen
dank